buenas noches como lo mencionas hace
varias horas se hizo oficial el anuncio
de la muerte de la reina isabel segunda
a sus 96 años y 70 años y siete meses en
el trono y como lo pueden ver a mis
espaldas todavía siguen llegando
miembros del público aquí a las afueras
del palacio de buckingham donde sigue
ondeando la bandera insignia de la
monarca de la reina isabel que sigue a
media asta siguen llegando hasta acá
para dejar mensajes de condolencias
flores para la familia real que hoy ha
perdido no solamente a su madre a su
abuela sino que el país se ha quedado
sin la jefa de estado una de las mujeres
más queridas de la historia una de las
mujeres más admiradas y respetadas
incluso por los sectores republicanos
que quieren que este país se convierta
en una república pero resaltan y
coinciden en la labor espléndida que ha
cumplido isabel segunda en 70 años de
reinado hemos visto familias enteras con
lo que con lágrimas se han acercado aquí
hasta el palacio de buckingham y éstas
una cena que veremos repetida a lo largo
de estos 10 días porque ese día décimo
será el funeral de estado de isabel
segunda un hecho sin precedentes en el
reino unido- y como les decía la gente
quiere recordar a la reina isabel como
eso con un símbolo de unidad de ese país
protagonista de nuestra historia
reciente la única reina que conocemos
millones de personas y de generaciones
enteras no sólo aquí en el reino unido
sino en todo el mundo protagonista
indiscutible del escenario internacional
que fue protagonista de la
transformación del entonces imperio
británico a lo que se conoce hoy colado
como la commonwealth que integran 56
países desde inglaterra hasta
territorios en el caribe el rey tercero
el rey carlos permanece en el castillo
de balmoral en escocia mañana volverá a
londres a las diez de la mañana --hora
local-- será oficialmente la ceremonia
con la que se convertirá rey el rey
tercero pero la ceremonia de ascensión
al trono que probablemente será en la
abadía de westminster podría tardar
hasta un año el rey carlos tercero se
reunirá mañana con la nueva ministra liz
tras que en esta semana ha completado un
récord que posiblemente ningún otro
ministro ha conocido y compartido con
dos reyes con la reina isabel hace
apenas dos días y hoy el viernes lo hará
con el rey tercero el k el rey carlos
tercero también el parlamento británico
que entra en un periodo de receso por el
luto nacional que vivirá el país por
diez días se reunirá mañana y el sábado
para rendir tributos a la reina isabel y
las imágenes que tendremos que recordar
estos últimos días serán justamente las
de la reina isabel hace dos días cuando
reciba su primera ministra número 15 el
primer primer ministro de la reina
isabel fue winston churchill así que
ella la vimos caminando apoyada con
dificultad con un bastón pero sonriente
esas son las imágenes que se quiere
llevar la reina isabel siempre
cumpliendo con su deber